last year I was living with this
indigenous family in India one afternoon
the young son was eating and at the
sight of me he quickly hit his curry
behind his back it took a lot of
persuasion to get him to show me what he
was eating it turned out to be Moss
larvae a traditional delicacy with the
Maurya indigenous people I cried
oh my god you're eating these I hope
there's a little left for me I thought
disbelief in the boy's eyes you eat
these I love these I replied I could see
he did not trust me one bit how could an
up an educated woman like the same food
as him later I broached the subject with
his father and it turned out to be a
mighty touchy affair he said things like
Oh only the son of mine likes to eat it
we tell him give it up it's bad he
doesn't listen you see we gave up eating
all this HS back frying I asked this is
your traditional food it is available in
your environment it is nutritious and I
can vouch for it delicious why is it
wrong to eat it the man fell silent
I asked have you been told that your
food is bad that eat it is backward not
civilized he nodded silently this was
one of the many many times in my work
with indigenous people in India that I
witnessed shame around food shame that
the food you love to eat the food that
has been
Eitan for generations is somehow
inferior even subhuman and this shame is
not limited to out-of-the-way iki foods
like insects or rats maybe but extends
to regular foods wild vegetables
mushrooms flowers basically anything
that is foraged rather than cultivated
in indigenous India this shame is
omnipresent anything can trigger it one
upper caste vegetarian schoolmaster gets
appointed in a school within weeks
children are telling their parents it's
yucky to eat crabs or sinful to eat meat
a government nutrition program serves
fluffy white rice now no one wants to
eat red rice or millets a nonprofit
reaches this village with an ideal diet
chart for pregnant women there you go
all the expectant mothers are feeling
sad that they cannot afford apples and
grapes and people just kind of forget
the fruits that can be picked off the
forest floor health workers religious
missionaries random government employees
and even their own educated children are
literally shouting it down at the
indigenous people that their food is not
good enough not civilized enough and so
food keeps disappearing a little bit at
a time I am wondering if you all have
ever considered whether your communities
would have a similar history around food
if you were to talk to your 90 year old
grandmother would she talk about foods
that you have never seen or heard of are
you aware how much of your community's
food is no longer available to you local
experts tell me that the South African
food economy is now entirely based on
imported foods
corn has become the staple while the
local Schalke
millets bulbs and tubers are all gone so
are the wild legumes and vegetables
while people eat potatoes and onions
cabbages and carrots in my country this
loss of food is colossal modern India is
stuck with rice wheat and diabetes and
we have totally forgotten foods like
huge varieties of tubers tree saps fish
shellfish oil seeds mollusks mushrooms
insects small non endangered animal
means all of which used to be available
right within our surroundings so where
has this food gone why are our modern
food baskets so narrow we could talk
about the complex political economic and
ecological reasons but I am here to talk
about this more human phenomenon of
shame because shame is the crucial point
at which food actually disappears off
your plate what is shame - shame makes
you feel small sad not worthy subhuman
shame creates a cognitive dissonance it
distorts food stories let us take this
example how would you like to have a
wonderful versatile staple that is
available abundantly in your environment
all you have to do is gather it dry it
store it and you have it for your whole
year to cook as many different kinds of
dishes as you want with it
India had just such a food called ma hua
this flower over there and I have been
researching this food for the past three
years now it
known to be highly nutritious in
indigenous tradition and in scientific
knowledge for the indigenous it used to
be a staple for four to six months a
year in many ways it is very similar to
your local marula except that it is a
flower not a fruit where the forests are
rich people can still get enough to eat
for the whole year and enough spare to
sell I found 35 different dishes with
maja that no one cooks anymore this fort
is no longer even recognized as a food
but as raw material for liquor you could
be arrested for having it in your house
reason shame I talk to indigenous people
all over India about why maha is no
longer eaten and I got the exact same
answer obvious to eat it when we were
dirt poor and starving why should we eat
it now we have rise of it and almost in
the same breath people also tell me how
nutritious maha is there are always
stories of elders who used to eat mawa
this grandmother of us she had 10
children and still she used to work so
hard never tired never sick the exact
same dual narrative every single where
how come how does the same food get to
be seen as very nutritious and a poverty
food almost in the same sentence same
goes for other forest foods
I have heard story after heart-rending
story of famine and starvation of people
surviving on trash forests out of the
forest because there was no food if I
dig a little deeper it turns out the
lack was not of food per se but
of something respectable like rice I
asked them how did you learn that your
so-called trash is edible who told you
that certain bitter tubers can be
sweetened by leaving them in a stream
overnight or how to take the meat out of
a snail shell or how to set a trap for a
while rat that is when they start
scratching their heads and they realized
that they learnt it from their own
elders that their ancestors had lived
and thrived on these foods for centuries
before rice came their way and were way
healthier than their own generation so
this is how food works how shame works
making food and food traditions
disappear from people's lives and
memories without their even realizing it
so how do we undo this trend how do we
reclaim our beautiful and complex
systems of natural food food given to us
lovingly by mother earth according to
her own rhythm food prepared by our
foremothers with joy and are eaten by
our forefathers with gratitude food that
is healthy local natural varied
delicious not requiring cultivation not
damaging our ecology not costing a thing
we all need this food and I don't think
I have to tell you why I don't have to
tell you about the global health crisis
climate change water crisis soil fatigue
collapsing agriculture systems all that
but for me
equally important reasons why we need
these foods are the deeply felt ones
because food is so many things you see
food is nourishment comfort
creativity community pleasure safety
identity and so much more how we connect
with our food define so much in our
lives it defines how we connect with our
bodies because our bodies are ultimately
food it defines our basic sense of
connection with our existence we need
these foods most today to be able to
redefine our space as humans within the
natural scheme of things and are we
needing such a redefinition today for me
the only real answer is love because
love is the only thing that counters
shame and how do we bring more of this
love into our connections with our food
for me love is in a big way about the
willingness to slow down to take the
time to feel sense listen and quire it
could be listening to our own bodies
what do they need beneath our food
habits beliefs and addictions it could
be taking time out to examine those
beliefs where did they come from it
could be going back into our childhood
what foods did we love them and what has
changed it could be spending a quiet
evening with an elder listening to their
food memories maybe even helping them
cook something they love and sharing a
meal love could be about remembering
that humanity is vast and food choices
differ it could be about showing respect
and curiosity instead of censure
when we see somebody enjoying a really
unfamiliar food love could be taking the
time to inquire to dig up information
reach out for connections it could even
be a quiet walk in the fame bus to see
if a certain plant speaks up to you that
happens they speak to me all the time
and most of all love is to trust that
these little exploratory steps have the
potential to lead us to something larger
sometimes to really surprising answers
an indigenous medicine woman once told
me that love is to walk on mother earth
as her most beloved child
tuturro trust that she values an honest
intention and knows how to guide our
steps I hope I have inspired you to
start reconnecting with the food of your
ancestors thank you for listening
[Applause]
you